Dr. King and A. Philip Randolph, John Lewis and Bayard Rustin,...
...Dorothy Height, Myrlie Evers, Daisy Bates...
...and all the others who led this massive march...
...knew what they were doing on this hallowed ground.
In the shadow of Lincoln's statue,...
...the burning memory of the fact that he gave his life to preserve the union and end slavery,...
...Martin Luther King urged his crowd not to drink from the cup of bitterness...
...but to reach across the racial divide...
...because, he said, we cannot walk alone.
Their destiny is tied up with our destiny.
Their freedom is inextricably bound to our freedom.
He urged the victims of racial violence to meet white Americans with an outstretched hand,...
...not a clenched hand,...
...and, in so doing, to prove the redeeming power of unearned suffering.
And then he dreamed...
...of an America where all citizens would sit together at the table of brotherhood,...
...where little white boys and girls and little black boys and girls would hold hands...
...across the color line.
Where his own children would be judged not by the color of their skin...
...but by the content of their character.
This march and that speech changed America.
They opened minds, they melted hearts and they moved millions,...
...including a 17-year-old boy watching alone in his home in Arkansas.